in the pantheon of video game archetypes
there are short games and then there are
short games for an example of the former
let's take a quick look at Star Fox 64
one of my personal favorites the primary
mode of the game is digestible in about
2 hours which would be blowing up
sensationalist game news headlines
everywhere if it came out today but
there was more to it than that there
were multiple different paths you could
take through the world map and it took
time and repetition to work out how
exactly to unlock more difficult levels
by triggering certain events because the
feedback loop of completing this game
and starting over again was so quick
there was a level of addictiveness and
playing up to a point where you knew you
were gonna find a new level and then
starting the whole game over if you
failed just to see what flying through
every stone arch on a particular map
might do there are a number of short
games out there that in spite or because
of their length are not only worth their
value but worth your small time
investment so I asked a handful of the
GameSpot staff for their favorites in
this category to gain some insight on
how a game can overcome its diminutive
size to deliver a big experience I
[ __ ] love journey other than being an
absolutely beautiful journey set a lot
by doing very little I wouldn't call it
minimalistic but it had a very very
short very to-the-point
storyline I guess you could call it and
it conveyed a lot of feeling through
pictures on walls and through collecting
collecting the cloth and stuff like that
and I think it it be it made you feel a
lot of things by giving you just enough
that you were able to interpret on your
own and I think an experience like that
wouldn't have worked if it was like a 8
10 12 hour experience which is why I
love that during these two hours you
have this very small very contained very
powerful narrative in this little to
three hour frame depending on how long
you want to spend in it so I think it's
the perfect size to be as powerful as it
is
[Music]
well done Android the enrichment center
once again reminds you that Android hell
is a real place where you will be sent
at the first sign of defiance portals
length really adds to the the enjoyment
of the game itself like I remember when
it first came out and some of my friends
played it before me and it was kind of a
contest within us like to see how
quickly each person could be - like they
told me this game takes about two or
three hours and in a way that was like a
challenge like the first my first
experience with portal was I know that
these are these are puzzles that I want
to get through and I've heard it has an
interesting story but like I just want
to see can I get through this in like
two or three hours but in those two to
three hours like even though it is about
like solving puzzles and and in gameplay
that isn't necessarily focused on a
narrative the narrative that they build
around it is just like so rich because
it's so tight because it just cuts out
all of the fact of course there are
games that are wonderful because they do
take so much time because you're looking
for resources and you're go riding
through quests and just you're spending
a lot of time being immersed in that
world portal is really good because it
is just such a quick experience and and
because it's so short you can go through
it multiple times like I think I play
through the original portal three or
four times because it was short because
I you know eventually I could get
through it in about an hour and I just
loved like looking for new little things
that they put in the game that I didn't
notice before it like that let length
actually adds to portal a lot
this fast so if you've ever had that
really good feeling when you pick up a
book and it's thick and it looks like
it's gonna be this big novel and you
open it up and the font is really huge
then you can breeze through the chapters
it's kind of like the way the vanishing
of Ethan Carter makes me feel it looks
like it's going to be this massive
substantial game but it's broken out it
is really easy to digest chapters it
starts you out in the very beginning
where you actually feel like there's
something going on in this world that
your your life is in danger
makes you really want to investigate
further and then all of a sudden you're
investigating crimes and each of these
crimes are actually pretty short to
uncover and figuring out how the scene
played out is such a great feeling it
makes you feel incredibly smart when you
finish it and so these are small chunks
of the game that you can piece out in 20
minutes or so you can actually beat the
entire game easily in one sitting it's
witty it's surprising and because the
game is so short once it does that about
ten or so times you actually have
completed the game and that's why the
game is is just so good in the length
that it is it doesn't need to be longer
it's perfect just the way it was and it
was a great way to spend one evening I
had one or two things in my life no
place is truly quiet and nowhere is
really ordinary so Metal Gear Ground
zeroes right this is a game that
everyone criticized for being only five
minutes long because it was reported
that a member on the dev team was able
to speed run the whole game in five
minutes well with that turned out not to
be true right there was one mission that
he was really good at playing and he got
through that pretty fast that said the
game isn't that long it's it's a pretty
short game but what it does have going
for it is the sort of open-ended nature
of it and what that lends to is
replayability and while that's not
always something that is worth praising
a game for the great part about Metal
Gear Solid Ground zeroes is the fact
that you can approach the five missions
in the game in so many different ways
and you know if you're someone who likes
stealth and who likes the Metal Gear
series you sort of get to it's like a
sample platter of what to expect in the
phantom pain so on the one hand you have
this great stealth experience that's
that's varied and yes it's an
location but you know the time of day
changes the missions change the guards
change you know it the variables get
mixed up on the other hand if you're a
metal gear solid fan it's a great little
taste of what's to come do I think that
you know the price helps justify its
length yes but at the same time you know
ground zeroes is something that I would
appreciate you know even as the $60
price tag because I like stealth games I
mean there's so many ways to sort of
play that that game and for me yes
there's a short experience but is also a
great experience I kept you waiting car
I'm gonna champion one particular short
game because that's what I was asked to
do and that game is vanquish it's not
really like anything else it takes
third-person shooting but then it
infuses that shooting with kind of that
PlatinumGames action game style that you
see in Bayonetta and games like that and
so you've really got what amounts to be
an action game with a lot of motion and
fluidity in which you happen to be
shooting instead of using swords to
slash enemies up and it's just it's
awesome with this great AI and and it's
also really high-energy all the time I
don't think that being longer would have
necessarily served thank 'wish well that
would rather play vanquish again and
again and again then play say lightning
returns once